yoky huh why don't you pump the brake
it's our last month in the Oval Office
hopefully be qualified for some
unemployment ain't no place in the
workforce for a real need ah damn it's
about to be Obama's last days as
president what's your fix
well hopefully you've well through some
Instagram models before the closing
ceremony yeah last days in the White
House he'd been I go out trying to be
faithful oh come on y'all how am I
supposed to make the NBA of Donald Trump
brings a miracle and it's me I say don't
worry cuz I'm probably gonna get mail
soon in Vegas casino isn't even on the
strip due to the pension what I say
don't try to ship us back to Africa well
i'ma let y'all worry about you
can't control and i'ma just keep being
lead well Jamal if you leave then
I'm LeBron J well if you LeBron
James oh my god from Forrest Gump the
white guy from white man can shut up
well you do look like Donald Trump
[Music]